[Musique]
on va à l'école directement ou alors le
petit déjeuner kaori un chapeau ne crois
pas là jean paul sartre et de manger à
sa faim chez vous si je comprends bien
nous avons là la bonne vie cinq jeux
vous savez tous que c'est à lire pour la
première fois les burundais pourront
choisir librement leur président de la
république papa c'est quoi la différence
entre les autos et les to think août ils
n'ont pas le même mais la guerre mais
après les hutus let it is parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le même territoire
vingt six ans le même pays ils ont la
même langue et vont la même église
laisse pas pourquoi la jebba cause de
leur nez si tu veux vivre ici tu seras
obligé de choisir son camp s'il choisit
pas tu vois pourquoi séparer la classe
en 2000 et a aucune pression
[Musique]
la gare a tout changé d'avis
en tout
se protège page 5
m
[Musique]